of the is 31 latest tweets three of them
mentioned tax cuts and by the way only
to acknowledge that it passed the
committee or to start tying the tax cuts
to the good economic news 7 tweets
talked about how great the economy is
doing
once we mentioned the NFL 3 mentioned
Melania Christmas or Melania and
Christmas two of them mentioned Matt
Lauer almost as many tweets mentioned
Matt Lauer as his legislative agenda 3
showed videos of Muslims doing terrible
things that's the same number as talking
about tax cuts 3 talked about fake news
one suggested the Joe Scarborough
murdered a staffer one of them told his
followers to look into NBC chairman Andy
Lacs past why is Trump tweeting about
these things it's because he's a
prestidigitator if you don't know that
word that's not like Amanda's name
breasted Giacomo's prestidigitator it's
a word for people of quick fingers like
a magician magic where it's a slate of
hand that is prestidigitation look over
here look at look over there what's that
and then when we're looking at that
thing something else is happening over
here so of all these tweets why is he
talking about each of these the economy
is obvious he's trying to try this try
the strong economy to his tax plan he
talks about how great the economy is
doing how great the economy is doing
he's building up his credibility on the
economy then he's saying we need this
new economic agenda this new economic
legislation why Matt Lauer Matt Lauer's
the biggest news of the day he has been
fired for apparent sexual assault in Rio
de Janeiro but I've apparently rampant
womanizing sexual harassment at NBC but
he doesn't just leave it in Matt Lauer
he doesn't just look it would be great
to revel in Matt Lauer going down that
guy is a jerk he's a left-wing hack he
was a jerk to President Bush when he
would interview him but he's not doing
that Trump isn't just leaving it in
schadenfreude he's tying it to Joe
Scarborough why because he's trying to
discredit the left wing attack daughter
media he's trying to paint with a much
broader brush that's why he's going
after NBC chairman Andy lack now why is
he tweeting about the NFL the NFL is a
culture culture point with that is
extremely popular for Donald Trump
he has broad agreement across the
country on this his approval rating is
doing a lot better than the NFL's
approval rating people are cutting cable
because of the shenanigans and
doing activism they see every night at
the NFL and why the Christmas tweets
well they they preview the war on
Christmas theme which we're already
beginning to see but I promise you were
gonna see more of it this month why the
Muslim videos the Muslim videos I think
tell a lot of the story he was
retweeting videos of Muslims doing awful
things attacking people and beheading a
statue of the Virgin Mary and they were
all posted by Jada Frandsen she's the
deputy leader of Britain first which is
a right-wing group and this woman who is
he doesn't follow her on Twitter right
he only follows 45 people on Twitter why
tweet her this is a woman who was found
guilty of a hate crime so the left is
freaking out about this they say he's
retweeting far-right criminals hate
criminals bigots whatever what was her
hate crime a simple Google search will
tell you her hate crime was saying that
Islam oppresses women that was the crime
because they don't have the First
Amendment over there and in the UK they
don't have freedom of speech you can be
convicted of a hate crime for just
saying something which is obviously true
obviously Sharia law isn't good for
women a rule that says that women need
to wear burlap sacks over them in Middle
Eastern heat that can't possibly be good
for women any concept we have on the
west of women's rights does not apply
now free speech though and PC these
aren't just random issues they're
central issues to Donald Trump's
popularity and and this is where the
claim breaks down why the the never
Trump right and his opponents on the
left
they say he's just crazy he's just
tweeting whatever there's no rhyme or
reason to it he's a madman with his
finger on the nuclear codes and the
other finger on Twitter there's no
evidence that Donald Trump hates Muslim
people there's no evidence in the four
decades that we've known about Donald
Trump we we've never seen these
allegations of bigotry before it clearly
it has to serve a strategic purpose or
we're suggesting that he just became a
bigot overnight that he just became in
his Lama folk overnight or something and
he just so happened to pick a woman that
ties in directly with his auntie PC Pro
free speech agenda it doesn't work at a
certain point either the guy just gets
lucky and lucky and lucky and he's
absurd
lucky at multiple things at one time for
40 years or he doesn't just have air
blowing between his ears he doesn't just
have nothing going on in his head he has
some strategic thought and a good gut
that tells him had a had a enacted
tactically so what is he not tweeting
about this is the actual story I'm
perfectly willing to talk about it
because it's a great wing for the
Republicans and for conservatives and
because the left-wing media doesn't
watch my show so I don't think I'm
telling any tales out of school or
pulling the veil up on this he isn't
talking about tax reform but what was he
doing yesterday Trump spent most of
yesterday on Capitol Hill bullying
Republican senators into voting for the
GOP tax reform in the Budget Committee
according to a Senate source for the
hill Trump went after Ron Johnson by
name quote this is in the hill he told
him to stop blocking it and to work out
his concerns with the rest of the
conference he told him he would have a
chance to offer amendments and he should
stop being an impediment Trump also
leaned on bob corker and James Lankford
both of whom are Republicans that
threatened to vote against the bill in
committee Senate GOP Whip John Corr and
said it was Trump strong-arming that
gave the bill quote a shot of adrenaline
it gave this bill that everyone has been
predicting on both sides of the aisle
it's going nowhere it's gonna die in
committee not so gave it some momentum
last month Trump also met with the
entire Senate GOP caucus to get them on
the same page on tax reform